[Music]
what is
a rival to you the biggest obstacle that
you have to overcome
the biggest source of competition the
biggest [ __ ] who is charming and you
just can't seem to hate
unlike the actual villains or maybe he's
the most reliable and strongest ally you
have on your side in a pinch i wonder
what makes a good rival for you however
we're mainly here today to talk about my
last point for all the animosity a rival
has with the anime protagonist
often he's the best ally a protagonist
can have and their team ups usually come
with one amazing culmination of history
and development between them or maybe
they just work so well together because
the competition between them make the
two equals in both plot importance and
power level whatever it is we're here
today to count down the top 10 rival
team ups in anime before starting off
the video i'd encourage you to hit that
subscribe button
it's such a joy to watch former allies
turned rivals and enemies reunite
and the best moment in the vein of
something like that has to be gintoki
teaming up with dakasugi once more the
two have had a long history
and their rivalry is actually one of the
biggest things that makes the story of
gintama so captivating for me after
seeing all that they've gone through
seeing them team up again and save each
other's comrades got me out of my seats
and they didn't come alone i just love
the mistrust and tension that exists
among the members just cause someone
helps you it doesn't mean you
automatically buddies with him already
still it's a dream reunion and a dream
team up waiting to happen and after more
than 300 episodes
we finally got it i know technically
speaking this wasn't the first time they
teamed up with each other that moment is
still one of my favorite moments in
gentama but it wasn't really much of a
fight was it so i went with this one
instead a perfect moment with the
perfect music playing in the background
now that's how you make a cliffhanger
[Applause]
[Music]
a good rival is someone who serves as
the perfect foil and who better to serve
as the laid-back yo
asakura's rival than the very intense
go-getter tauren
shaman king is one of the first shows
that helped me get accustomed to the
rival dynamic in anime as well as the
concept of foils so the moment where
they take on tao yuan is an extra
special climax in my opinion the whole
arc's been one
very important one for ren and made him
one of my favorite characters at that
time it's a given that key rivals and
shonen anime get a whole arc or two
devoted to developing them but ren's
journey is something that i resonated
with as an elementary student back then
to see him finally take the stand and
fight alongside his eternal rival first
true friend was a joy to watch the best
news about this fight
shaman king is coming back so you can
now look forward to seeing the
remastered version of this fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
then
our next moment is probably the biggest
one among these moments
in sheer scale in the medium battle in
maggie i didn't mention any specific
character for this moment because this
is a fight that involves all kingdoms in
the world of magi it started with an
invasion on mage kingdom then the coral
empire comes in with its best warriors
and even simbad and the seven caesar
lions come into the picture and show off
a lot of their flashy abilities one
after another oh yeah and did i mention
that all these kingdoms have tensions
with each other this is truly a grand
moment that deserves to be the series
grand finale in the anime adaptation the
world of magi is just full of so many
interesting political dynamics and
battles of ideals but seeing everyone
put their differences aside for the sake
of the world is just
amazing and heartwarming i wanted to
place this fight a bit higher but i
can't because for all the stunning
visuals this
one has and the implications it has on
the story moving forward the fight is
actually quite repetitive it's just
people
spamming extreme magic one after another
on the medium that no sells it before
someone else comes in and does the same
rinse and repeat until the medium
finally goes down right when almost
every named character
has entered the scene
remember yu-gi-oh yugi and kaiba have
such a storied rivalry that it's amazing
to see how well they actually work well
in the battle against loomis and
[Music]
umbra
granted work well is more of looking at
the end result for most of the
admittedly long joule
yugi and kyber just can't seem to get
along in a tag duel like the one they
had
not getting along or not playing along
with your partner it's just so costly we
can thank the fact that they're main
characters
otherwise i doubt that any random duo
would last that long against the mars
bros
teamwork the notable thing about this is
that despite all the tension and
bickering between the two yugi and gaiba
actually have good reads on each other's
plans and the duel reaches its climax
with some unexpected sacrificial plays
for the greater good from yugi's
arrogant rival nonetheless as the fight
progresses we can see
team chemistry slowly shifting from one
team to another through teeth clenched
teamwork the pair manages to win the
duel in an awesome way with the
summoning of one of the egyptian gods
[Music]
things are about to get heated up in our
next fight natsu and garjiel
versus laxus up to this day i still find
the battle of fairy tale arc of fairy
tale one of my favorites in the entire
series the series has come a long way
and i still think that the first few
arcs of fairy tale are still amazing in
comparison to the latter ones one of my
favorite moments from old school fairy
tale comes in the form of natsu teaming
up with the previous arcs arch nemesis
in gajiel i like this rival team up due
to the tension in it up until this point
all good will
and trust that guardiol's gotten from
his new guild are of the begrudging type
guard yields a true wild card in this
especially considering the scenes prior
to the battle however when the time
comes to turn the tides of the decisive
battle who else better to answer the
call than the same dragon slayer that
gave nazi so much trouble
to arcs prior the two would later team
up against two other dragon slayers but
i gave this moment the nod because i
feel it's more memorable after all when
the tag battle happened gargiel had
already long become a mainstay ally and
a member of fairy tale in this one you
can still feel the teeth clench teamwork
and the animosity between him and natsu
plus this fight
had a more epic finish
while the rival is the anime character's
best buddy and strongest
ally allow me the pleasure of
introducing to you your number one
partner in crime on the internet
and the sponsors of this video
expressvpn
imagine watching series on your bare
bones netflix or your crunchyroll that
has like a quarter of the available
titles
such a pain right well luckily
expressvpn is here to help you vanquish
those
pesky region locks with the click of a
button i mean really it's that simple
just open the interface click your
server of choice and voila
say bye bye to those region locks
forever there are so many vpn options
out there but nothing can even match
expressvpn
in terms of safety convenience and plain
ease of use
and if you have other concerns they have
the best customer service available with
representatives answering your questions
in real time and i can teach you how to
avail of such an amazing service
all you have to do is click the link
below and avail of the free 3 month
service there's no better time to jump
in than now
so make sure to check out the link below
or go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube and get your hands on your
strongest and most reliable buddy on the
internet
[Music]
as we approach the tail end of the list
i think it's about time to feature one
hell of a climax in atsushi and aku
tagawa versus francis
what a way to end the second season of
bungo stray dogs two eternal rivals that
have been going at each other for so
long as i can remember finally getting
the team up for a lifetime as they take
on francis
atop the moby dick a fight as epic and
hyped as this is just the perfect way to
send off yet another excellent season
the fight itself is cool but what i like
the most about this is the character
development at work for both atsushi and
akutagawa it's a fight that showcases
the resolve and growth they've gone
through as characters and it shows that
if they work together cohesively the
powers actually make a pretty damn good
combination this is probably one of the
best
team ups for me and i got goosebumps
seeing atsushi and akutagawa work
together as the epic opening players in
the background
the top rivalry in the new generation of
mainstream shonen has to be deku and
bakugo i don't think that anything from
the currently running mainstream shonen
can compare to the history of these two
and how intertwined their fates are fans
who watched my hero academia
heroes rising got a big and cathartic
treat in the form of their final battle
against
nine it's a fight that the duo lost
earlier in the movie but as you know
such defeats are but minor setbacks for
our plucky shonen heroes as such they
take another crack at it much later in
the movie the fight's pretty much what
you'd expect from a climactic fight in
my hero academia
but with one very important addition
that ties up deku and bakugo's rivalry
really well the power the bakugou had
wanted for so long finally comes to his
grasp
one for all the crux of the two's
rivalry intention
finally gets transferred to bakugo the
visual of bargugo using detroit smash
alongside deku is one of the moments
that i'll forever remember
for our runner up on the list we have
goku and vegeta versus broly name a pair
of rivals more iconic than good old goku
and vegeta given the long history and
how much the two have codified
themselves as top rivals in anime
history finding an answer to that would
be difficult that's why everyone
collectively lost their [ __ ] when they
teamed up to take on an even bigger foe
in broly the team up is what makes the
broly movie so memorable when vegeta was
first introduced
anyone savvy enough with anime would
know that it would only take little time
for him to become one of those reluctant
allies of the good guys but to see him
fight alongside goku in this capacity
was simply breathtaking for someone as
strong as broly it would take nothing
less than the combined might of the two
most iconic dragon ball characters to
take him down and we got ourselves a
battle for the ages
uh
actually there is a pair of rivals that
are just as if not even more iconic than
goku and vegeta and they are naruto and
sasuke the rivalry between the two has
been the major driving point of the
entire series so seeing them team up in
boruto creates a rather interesting
dynamic for one they're adults now
it's a completely different dynamic that
they have compared to when they were the
angsty and emotional teens that were in
the whole run of naruto
now as adults the fight gives us a
longing sense of how times passed us by
while tickling our nostalgia goggles by
showing off the two characters signature
abilities along with us
naruto and sasuke have come a long way
from where they were in the previous
series this is one of the shining points
of boruto's much criticized anime and i
don't think that the nostalgia alone is
the prime reason for it that would be a
disservice to the amazing animation team
in this fight
who brought their a-plus game for this
moment the fight carries with it a sense
of much-needed continuity and nostalgic
progression which is mainly why i picked
this fight to top the list
as we on the list i want to know which
one amongst these rival team ups do you
find to be your favorite and why i'd
love to hear your thoughts out in the
comments section down there below
so make sure to leave some thoughts
before leaving oh and before you go
make sure to like the video and hit the
subscribe button if you enjoyed the list
seeing the community grow is something
that makes me really happy i'd love to
reach that next milestone for this
channel
i know that together we can do it don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now for
now that's it please stay tuned for the
next list
stay safe stay cool and stay awesome
see ya
[Music]
you